margaret the fel omen probably the first
plateau that you're gonna hit in elden
ring depending on where you go obviously
this is the first main boss that you're
going to face now what you're gonna see
in this video is me basically figuring
out how this boss works that is kind of
how all souls games work is that you try
to figure that out based on the distance
you need to be in the direction that you
need to roll based on the attacks that
they give you over and over again a lot
of these bosses have lots of different
attacks they do but they have the same
tells so you know what they're about to
do and you'll see the process of me
figuring it out and then you will see me
successfully beat the boss and make it a
lot easier so if you're specifically
struggling with this boss just watch
this video we figure it out pretty
easily and you're not gonna have a hard
time at all next time you give it a try
thanks for watching guys go tell
somebody you love them i'd appreciate if
you sub to the channel too have a great
day you know what we should do we should
try and fight
fight the man i think we should try and
fight the man boys
what do you think i mean give it a try
we're we're stronger than we were can i
get help from our boy again oh i can't
nice
yeah we're doing way more damage than
before
way more damage
oh nice nice
roger no
damn
our boy is dead
oh big hit
i think my sight my sight literally does
crit damage holy [ __ ] and then he own me
roger wanted every bit of smoke that guy
offered holy [ __ ] this guy's hard let's
see if roger wants some more smoke roger
do you want some more smoke
i was trying to roll
nice
okay i'm cool with that
very cool with that come on roger i need
you bro
damn roger oh no
[Music]
oh my god these these moves are crazy
bro i don't know how i applied a bleed
earlier he's [ __ ] nuts holy crap
the heck it didn't even work
i don't know how you dodged this guy
it's really difficult i died before
roger roger did
roger
roger sucks
like how the [ __ ] do you dodge that i
really don't know
maybe we just don't get close i want him
to go for the big attacks
like i want him to go for that because
it's way easier to dodge
i think that's key is keep the distance
wait for him to go for the big attack
and then you get the you get one down
yeah there's a lot of different [ __ ] and
then he starts using swords in both
hands very very tough and we can beat
him though i feel it i feel it in my
bones i think keeping distance on the
second phase
is key you just gotta dodge the incoming
like
shitty throws
like we those attacks right there that's
what we
want we want those those attacks
specifically
well i'm assuming everyone would
struggle with this guy for sure
no we didn't get him
it doesn't do that much actually it's
okay
roger stop getting hit by everything
well not good
heal
keep distance keep distance like i said
like i said
yep that's what we want right there
actually now that roger's alive
i think we're going for it
it's a sword and a hammer
rip roger bro
bye roger okay we're going for the win
boys
keep the distance
yep
this is fine
keep the distance
let him let him close in
i think that's the secret
come on
come on
go for a big boy attack you know you
want to
yep
then we gotta get out of there
keep the distance heal up
so we don't die one shot
oh i got stuck
why am i sneaking
panic panic ensues
that's what we want
huge
hopefully a big nope he didn't go big
we want those long attacks
yep
dodge right at the end re-hit
yup
no big no big
we're just keeping the distance this is
great this is perfect
i'm just getting it out of the way
come on
come on
yup
i think i figured him out
trying to sorta
yup
i'm just going for it bro let's go i
figured him out yes
that is the secret to him you keep the
distance in the second phase and then
it's not that bad
holy [ __ ]
nice
you're dead so your words are irrelevant
[ __ ]
let's go
yes sir
holy [ __ ] you said asu is struggling
with him right now let's go we beat asus
we got 9 000 runes from that 9k
damn